hi so um yeah thanks for the organizers
for giving me the opportunity to speak
here
um I'm going to present work that was
started when all these people were
together at ekh Zurich and it's a
testament I guess to the mobility of
Academia that we now spread out over two
continents and one Island
um several grand
um and yeah so when I submitted the
abstract I wasn't actually aware that
Matthias Cassandra was a participant of
this entire semester as far as I can
tell he hasn't actually talked about it
if he has were then you can just kind of
hear about it again
um all right so um here's the outline of
my talk I it's I have a bit of room that
this is a semi-diverse audience so so
every part of my talk will we bore
roughly a third of you right so
and there is an open problem yeah I hope
um
that will that will board two-thirds who
can't contribute to it but uh one third
should be a very um yeah very awake here
okay so I will um State the problem very
basically so for yeah just using basic
math new footage required I will then
tell you why I care about it and I'll
present the results and indeed a no
problem which I'd like to get some input
on and here's a spoiler uh the spoiler
for the geometers is this is going to be
just another application of moment map
geometry and the spoiler for the applied
people here is uh you should learn about
moment geometry
so here's the setting we have n finite
Hubert spaces and we're going to take
some normalized tensor in their product
and normalizes with respect to the
scalar product that these filbert spaces
carry so that's the setting and now
we're going to do the following
construction which is going to be a bit
our talk now and I'm I'm going to spend
the like the middle part of my talk
motivating why that is an important
construction namely they say an
azmorphism which is non-canonic for
those who care about that
um from this um
product of of uh of from the center
product to the linear maps from one of
the factors into all the others right
with the one removed
and there's various ways of of writing
out what I mean by this one is in
coordinates if you think Matlab right so
then this tensor with respect to some
product basis is an array of numbers and
you can group all the indices together
except for one and then you get some
very rectangular Matrix right from let's
see if these are if every single space
is two-dimensional it's going to be two
by two to the N minus one dimensional
Matrix
well it's a standard that the V tensor W
is as more to the homomorphosis of V2 to
V Star yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
here's another way of of writing the
same in terms of wiring diagrams so for
those who like that so the tensor has a
lot of indices every index here is
represented by one of these lines and
what I basically do is I I turn one of
them around to make it a a map that
accepts inputs here and outputs on the
product of the other spaces there will
be many wiring diagrams
visualizing things
all right
so what we're going to be interested in
is we're going to be interested in the
Square singular values of these Maps
right there's one map for every for
every space and there are singular
values are the objects you want to study
uh all right how does it work again
there's two ways of looking at it here's
the Matlab here's the Matlab way you
take this tensor you um yeah multiply it
with its edge with its uh complex
conjugate and then you you contract all
these uh indices that occur twice using
a summation convention and you leave
just
uh the J J's index Leaf open and then
you get a matrix and and the eigenvalues
of that Matrix that are going to be the
squared singular values of the map I
defined before and you can again do that
graphically this makes more sense maybe
this way of writing it so uh these
little loops mean you contract you
contract these indices and just two will
be left open
and everything and that is you unfold
the tensor and take singular bodies
yes yeah everybody has a different way
of talking about it exactly it's a
single levels of an unfolding right I've
never used that word before but it makes
sense this picture makes sense because
then you can see it's uh that the
singular values are actually bases
independent because uh yeah so so what
you take is you take the tensor you take
it's it's adjoint and then you um apply
this partial Trace
yeah a partial Trace means you contract
matching indices but not all of them and
so it is the trace except for the JS
index which remains open all right
um okay
here's now the problem
so we can we can generate any of these
Maps let's call them Row one to row N
and with every such map I want to
associate uh
yeah it's it's eigenvalues so there's
going to be a vector of eigenvalues
Lambda J there's a d numbers they are
non-negative because it's uh yeah it's
eigen values of an auto product uh yeah
of an operator times it's adjoint and so
I collect all these eigenvalues into one
big Vector I call that mu of PSI so it's
the vector where just stack them all
together so it's now an element of R
into the D
and the problem I I would like to look
at is
what exactly is the set of vectors that
kind of rise this way so what is the
region Delta which is the image of all
normalized tensors under this map so
it's going to trace out some region in
Sorry probably not sorry
well let's see okay so if you're in the
trades also region in r d to the N it's
probably not going to be disconnected
right because it's a connected domain
and a continuous map you said it's not
going to be you said it's so non-convex
well okay maybe you yeah okay of course
it will turn out to be convex but I
wanted to make here that that's a huge
surprise to the uninitialized right
there is no reason uh I can think of
why this would be convex it will turn
out to be convex all right so what it
doesn't know by this reminds me of the
one problem favorite
that should remind you of the whole
problem so the spoiler alert yeah
yes yeah right okay so um
well
um yeah anyway there's a refinement we
can I will make a bit more specific
later namely how does this image depend
on certain Global properties of the
tensor and I will say say later what I
mean precisely by global properties
okay so um yeah being faced with this
problem of course is an obvious question
that most of you are asking yourself
namely
why would anyone care about that region
that's a fair question
so let me uh try to
introduce it and yeah and to this uh
purpose I will have to teach you quantum
mechanics I'm the second one to do so
today so I don't know uh probably
akimasa will uh will do it for a third
time somewhere in the audience uh hi
yeah third time so yeah after three
introductions to Quantum Mechanics I
hope everybody knows what the theory is
all about
um uh but before before I actually teach
it to you maybe here's a teaser which
was a slide I I had when I talked about
that to a physics route because my
introduction was so extremely uh
Technical and that was something which
is maybe a bit uh overstating it but but
more Vivid and then we're gonna go for
the precise compromise in the middle uh
all right okay so there's a piece of
pork wisdom that's attributed to
Schrodinger who said in 1935 uh
paraphrasing Aristotle uh the whole is
greater than the sum of its parts when
when we talk about uh entangled Quantum
States and I will explain to you what he
meant by that and so our reaction to
that is certainly but by how much right
so we yeah we
I'll explain what Schrodinger meant by
that and and in which way the solution
to the problem I just sketched will give
a quantitative answer to yeah to this
quip
and yeah one way of of
um of saying what we're going to do and
this will make no sense at the moment
but I'll explain all the words in the
next half hour or so the task is to
completely classify the information
about the entanglement class of global
globally pure States
maybe those information that those
pieces of information that can be
accessed from single site information
single site information alone all right
there's a bit this should sound very
cool but there's too many informations
in here so we have some Global local
problem here that we can solve
all right okay so let me now explain all
this all you need to do know about
Quantum States what is quantum mechanics
uh yeah
that's a famous picture of uh eight ions
trapped in a linear electromagnetic trap
and we'll we'll come back to some
properties of that picture later all
right okay so um let's look at it from a
probability yeah a quantum mechanics is
a probabilistic theory and so let's try
to explain to you how it is different
from classical probability theory that
you know so classical probability
distributions on on the outcome space
are described by the non-negative
Numbers Pi adding up to one so nobody
surprised you
so to go Quantum you do the following
you are you taken an empty d by D Matrix
then you write your probability
distribution on the main diagonal
so that's what you do here and then you
do something that doesn't exist
classically namely you apply unitary
basis change so you get a new Matrix now
which is uh something yeah which looked
like a probability distribution
diagonally embedded but now in some in
some bases
so the result is a positive
semi-definite Matrix row which is called
a density operator in that context
and it describes Quantum probabilities
so in a nutshell Quantum probability is
Basis independent probability Theory you
have an added degree of freedom
okay so now we know about Quantum States
now we have to learn what the
counterparts are namely
um random Quantum random variables a
classical random variable is a vector in
in Rd
and expectation values are inner
products so the expectation value of
that random variable under the
distribution p is just the inner product
between the vector describing the random
variable and the probability
distribution
now in Quantum unsurprisingly uh random
variables are again matrices so Quantum
random variables are hermitian matrices
d by D matrices and the expectations are
again Trace again in our products and
this time they are Trace in the products
so if I have a Quantum system that is in
the state row whatever that means and I
measure the observable a or this Quantum
random variable a then the expectation
value of of my observable outcomes will
be the trace inner product between these
two matrices
and yeah
these kind of numbers are actually row
is a d by D hermitian Matrix also yeah
semi-definite
that was just like yes but I travel
there's a lot of slides that's right
there will be many more
all right there we go
um exactly but yeah that's it
and so these are the numbers that
actually can be extracted from
experiments and making predictions about
this number that's what physics is all
about
all right and Quantum random variables
have a cooler name they're called
observables I will use this word all the
time
um
right so then uh people have used the
word uh pure State uh before so let me
remind you what the pure state is and of
course there's a what a warning here
namely um the word pure is used in a
different way here than than many people
use it for tensors Pure means well I
will explain it but it's oh yeah just be
alert it will be different from the
meaning in which it has been used so far
okay so let's again uh compare yeah
compare classical and Quantum uh estate
spaces what you see here is the
classical State space of a three outcome
experiment for example a coin that could
fall down heads or tails or on the side
right so there are three possible
outcomes uh and uh and if I if I if I
toss it then there will be a probability
distribution telling me how likely one
of each of the three outcomes is there
are the extreme points of that convex
set these are the deterministic
configurations for example a coin which
always comes down head always comes down
tail or always on the side oh
or always on the side probably not so
often but anyway right and so extreme
points of probability of the set of
probability distribution these are
deterministic configurations and there's
yeah there's no Randomness going on and
arguably they are very boring from the
point of view of probability Theory
nothing is happening it's very different
Quantum mechanically it's again uh yeah
let's now look at the quantum mechanical
State space
it's uh yeah it's a it's a space of
Trace one semi-definite matrices the
extreme points are the rank one
semi-definite matrices which look like a
deterministic uh distribution in the
eigen bases but then there's still the
unitary decrease of feeding that we have
so very much unlike the classical
situation the extreme points of State
space are actually very interesting it's
a very rich object because you got the
spaces freedom it's of course a rank one
semi-definite Matrix is just this
equivalent to the outer product of some
normalized Vector type sign
and yeah these are the vectors that jila
for example talked about all the time
all right
and the extreme points of State space
they are called Pure states which is not
at all at all at all the same as pure
tensors uh namely which I would call
product tenses right at the moment
there's no tensor product here but it
will be introduced in a second in
practice the pure ones are most
important yep okay fine I think you get
the point
all right
uh my final slide and then you know
everything about quantum mechanics is
um we need to understand how to how to
model composite systems that Encompass
many yeah many particles at once for
example these eight ions
all right so the Hilbert space
associated with a composite system is
the tensor product of the single
particle Hubert spaces
so yeah something like this if you have
eight ions each having two degrees of
freedom as you have here then it would
be C2 tensor c2a times
um it's typical it is one different
uh the regime in which physicists works
is different from the regime many of the
applied mathematicians work namely uh we
typically have that the local Dimension
is very small two for example is a very
common value but the number of factors
can be very high right people work in
the thermodynamic limit where there's
infinitely many particles but hundreds
or thousands would be a totally normal
number people have to deal with
right so that the regime we are mostly
interested in
um all right and so now in this in this
context of of many particle systems both
the state so the density operators the
semi-definite matrices and also the
observables are our linear operators on
the sensor product space
now comes a very important concept
namely
um all right so if you have a system
like this in your lab then the
measurements you can physically perform
probably will involve only one particle
at a time always
right so you can shine laser on on that
particular iron as I do now and the way
it responds tells you about its inner
State and these measurements are
described by observables which act
non-trivially non-trivially only on one
tensor Factor so yeah so this big
two to the N times 2 to the N Matrix e
to the N times t to the N Matrix has the
structure of being mostly identities on
on most factors and something
non-trivial only on one factor that's
the most common thing people can
actually do and if you take the trace of
row times there you go again yeah total
Trace yeah okay and then we'll I'll have
a picture about this in just one second
maybe here actually aha right okay
thanks for anticipating that it's very
good uh no excellent so um all right so
with the subscription we can connect
back to these row J's remember these are
funny
um uh no unfoldings right these these
other product of those unfoldings uh
that I introduced before and now we can
see where they come from namely we take
we look at the falling situation we have
a a state row which is pure so again
it's the outer product of of some vector
and that Vector comes from this tensor
product pivot space and then I would
like to find a formula for This Global
Trace
and there is a simple way I mean okay
you can just see abstractly this is
going to be
um a this defines some linear function
just on this a AJ and so I want to find
a form for the linear function and I and
the claim is it's just going to be the
small Trace with respect to this row J
Matrix that I introduced in the
beginning
one side
uh yeah okay sorry I missed so let's
just go back to your slide where you
were sure
um so why is rho just a tensor product
of a bunch of things yeah row is not I
don't know what row J means
yes so aha that two answers one answer
is row J is uh the thing that I
introduced here before I told you why
you should care
uh there aha
did you not notice these two dots right
that was the definition of Roger you
should have noticed uh no exactly so
it's it's it these are contractions of
these unfoldings right these are my
Rojas and now and at the time I
introduced them because I can just talk
about them just in terms of tensors and
unfoldings but actually they have
there's a physical reasons for looking
at that and the physical reason is this
um the physical reason of this namely
that they uh yeah they tell us how local
measurements will behave and there's a
claim and where there's a claim there's
a proof and the proof is by uh homotopy
I guess of of wiring diagrams right you
uh anyway just let me walk you through
it uh you you see it already but uh for
me for me again so that I remember yeah
so as soon as if it's called Roja is
linear in your notation there or Junior
is sort of quadratic in the interests of
J you know it's quadratic in in size
all right okay so okay so if I if I just
take this left hand side and I write it
as a wiring diagram I will get this this
block here is just row it's the outer
product of PSI
uh it will yeah there will be a a matrix
product with identities everywhere
except for on on space j
and then I take the global trade the
global Trace means I contract all these
indices
so I have these little loops
and I can just I don't know stretch it a
bit and we we yeah and and why did this
way and you may recall that this was
just the definition of row J
right and so uh yeah it gets composed as
a matrix with AJ and then you take the
single side Trace
all right so then the take-home message
here is these Matrix matrices row J
describe the state of particle J right
so you have a composite system and the
state of a single particle is described
by that Matrix so in a way these are
quantum analogs of a of a marginal
distribution that's what they are
okay so we are interested in quantum
marginals
all right so now you know enough about
quantum mechanics is that we can put
things together uh that was my wild
claim the whole is greater than the sum
of its part and by how much that we can
say now and um all right here's the
story now
so if the global if the global row is
Extreme so it's pure it's a it's a it's
a it's yeah it's um its spectrum is one
zero zero zero then this does not imply
that the marginals are also pure are
also extreme that is different In
classical probability Theory right if I
have yeah if I have two coins and there
is no Randomness associated with the
state of the two coins then also if I
looked at the single coin there will be
no Randomness associated with it with
each coin by by themselves and that is
different in quantum mechanics you can
have something that is globally as well
specified as it only could be but
locally this is not the case the the
word JS will not uh look like this they
will have non-trivial Spectrum
if you're about to answer this ignore it
um if you know all the road Jays yes uh
to what extent what can you recover
about Psy
um we're gonna we're gonna ask the
inverse question so not much right
that's the point I mean uh yeah that's
yeah I mean just by counting dimensions
of course you lose a lot of information
there's not much what you can do in
general uh what I'm going to ask is the
inverse question namely if I know that
the global row is pure it's extreme
what could can possibly happen for the
local ones and so what so what
trillinger had in mind when he said this
was up that this realization by itself
there could be Global rules that are as
well specified as possible but the local
ones they exhibit randomness and so now
um and we are asking the the more
precise question namely asking for the
eigenvalues of all those four J's
um
if the quantitative version of this
problem so just exactly what kind of
local Randomness is compatible with
globe being globally as well specified
as possible
all right
does that make sense
that's why we can
all right
um I want to before I give you um yeah
before I tell you how to answer that
question I want to fine grain it a bit
more uh namely I want to post additional
constraints on the global tensor other
than that and subscribe by some yeah
that is described by by an auto product
by rank one pure extreme state
and this connects back to uh gilas talk
all right
um a pure state is entangle I really
don't like this word anymore because
some of it's used so often and uh and
people always struggle to get the
meaning so again anyway I have to
introduce it again so a piece it's
entangled if it's not a product
and again pure here means the density
operators of rank one and this property
I described as being a product and
that's not being a pure tensor
all right
and in a bit more detail as Gila will
introduced in this talk uh it makes
sense
um to say that two Pew states are in the
same entanglement class or that they are
equivalent in some way if they lie in
the same orbit of um of sld to the n
uh um action on the tensor product space
right so direct us to 10 sine Phi are
equivalent in that sense if and only if
I can map the one onto the other by a
product of a cells
and now I can refine my question and I
can ask the following given an
entanglement Class C so some SL orbit
what is the set of local eigenvalues
that can arise from tensors in the
closure of this class
I can ask this question for every where
we orbit
and okay so here are now the results
um
okay so it turns out that for each class
C the set Delta C of of local
eigenvalues that are compatible with it
is convex
right which um Mr Frank would not find
surprising but actually he didn't see
okay so it's it's it's it's a convex
head and even more it's a polytope right
um okay so I guess those people who no
no that's fine
those people who know about moment maps
of course may not be so surprised but um
it's if you if you if you're new to that
I think it's it's a remarkable concept
because I don't know somehow you take a
high dimensional sphere where all these
normalized side tenses live and you take
the other product project it down
there's no reason whatsoever to suspect
that you get something convex or even
Polito like
right
uh okay so these things have a name so
in the in a way we've just um like
identified uh the link between the
question and physics and a well-known
concept and geometry namely they are
non-commutative moment-body tropes or
clear one polytops associated with the
scoop action on uh on this orbit
and
um yeah uh sort of some more facts so
even though the the global Hilbert space
May decompose into into infinitely many
such classes
um yeah described by exponentially many
parameters as you've heard before lunch
uh there are only finitely many such
politopes so they give you a very coarse
grain picture on these on these orbits
which is bad and good at the same time
so maybe they are more tractable and in
fact yes in small Dimensions we can use
representation Theory to compute them
explicitly many means there's only
finally many sets which can arise as the
image or as how like you know of the
translation
in the situation that you could move the
facets out
yeah
all right so in this sense we can
enumerate all locally accessible
signatures of global entanglement right
so the global entanglement is some of
the information which of these orbits
are you in and exactly and and forget
what signatures means yeah well okay so
all the information it has no precise
meaning all the information that is
accessible if you just have no weight
but I'm just giving it to you it's all
the information that you can get about
about see if you just look if you just
have access to to measurements on a
single particle
right then it's exactly the yeah it's
exactly uh which of these poly terms am
I am I in right and then if I if I see
some constellation aspective that is
incompatible with a certain Polito I can
just disregard these orbits so I know
I'm not in one of these orbits that's
exactly what I can get out locally
I mean the fact alone that that one yeah
that one can make statements like this
about a global property just looking at
these locally accessible quantities I
guess that's surprising and it's
important because in actuality that's
what you have access to right you can
shine laser on one of these and it's
just it's very difficult to to read the
information that involves more of them
more more than one at the same time can
you explain what the picture would be in
the context of the EPL Paradox in the
context of the EPL Paradox like the
simplest possible example uh yes I will
get there
yeah it's gonna be nice
yeah line segment right so it's very
simple uh okay so um yeah I I cannot
introduce Africa there's two types of
people here those who know about moment
maps and those who will not learn it
from me today
um so I will I I will not get into the
details I just make some statements uh
and then I I have one slide where I give
you a feeling where one can
derive something very easy namely how
this simple situation looks like using
very complicated methods that however
generalize okay so it does some random
facts about this so there's many um
there's many different settings in which
one can prove results uh for our result
we just use the
by pre-owned and here's the statements
and those I guess who will attend this
uh lecture this evening they will they
will re-encounter all that a bit later I
I please anyway let me make the
statement and then you'll be the judge
all right so we we take this orbit we
take uh the uh homogeneous polynomials
on that on that orbit of degree cave uh
C is an SL over so SL also acts on on
these polynomials in this way anyway
also we have seen that uh in the last
talk and so now I look at all the um all
the e-webs uh of of this product group
that that I can see in the in in in this
uh space of liquid K polynomials
um they will be um described by a
collection of a Young die of young
frames one for every factor and now note
that if I take these young frames and I
divide them by K I get something that
formally looks like a probability
distribution right it's a bunch of
non-negative numbers adding up to one
and some two things that look similar
surely must be the same and in this case
nature or math whatever God is kind
enough to actually make that happen
namely um if I if I take these uh young
frames I renormalize them I get formally
distribution then then this distribution
will be a collection of Spectra that's
actually contained in this uh in this
poly tube and this way I get everything
so the points I get this way are dense
right so the polytops correspond to
normalize ewebs um in the in the
homogeneous coordinate over over their
orbit
so it's K varies you get all that ah yes
yes
okay so what's Delta C it's a Simplex of
Dimension ND minus one it's a polytope
what's the ambient setting so this is uh
inside ND space uh yeah yeah exactly n
times C but you normalize it to it being
an ND minus one-dimensional simple
it's actually nd1 I show you something
is actually ND minus one right there's
one redundant degree of freedom because
we look at normalized tenses the product
is simple C is one for each
that was my question when you normalize
all together but you're not normalizing
seven I normalize uh you know each of
them is normalized automatically so I
normally I normalize the tensor so it's
a product of synthesis It's contained
all right okay so then let's let me give
you three examples
um yeah one is I will give you a very
complicated way for seeing something uh
very basic namely that singular values
are invariant undertaking the transpose
of a matrix right that is actually the
same as this problem for only two tensor
factors because in two tens of factors
there's two sub such Maps I can
construct
by like yeah I don't know unfolding with
respect to the one or the other index
and this will just give me two maps
which are the transpose of each other so
there are similar values should better
be the same but that's essentially also
the only constraint except for lying in
the Tuple room right also they have to
be non-negative and some to one in this
case
all right so what we have to get out is
yeah using this uh fairly involved
language we have to get out this result
namely that the the Spectra of of the
first and of the second uh uh marginal
should be the same
all right so here's the computation now
um okay so we look at okay so there's no
uh yeah we don't do it on an orbit we do
it on the entire space which is
basically the same way anyway so we look
at the polynomials yeah this end should
probably be a k for consistency right
whatever so it's a it's yeah there
should be a k so we look at the
polynomials on the tensor product
so this yeah the symmetric space the
symmetric space is uh the Subspace
stabilized by the symmetric group
now we rearrange some tensor factors
yeah also that we saw before uh now on
every factor I use sure wide reality to
decompose it into a sum of e-wraps of
the symmetric group and the NSL
uh s and only acts on the MU on this uh
yeah on the on the e-wraps of the
semantic group so I can
again rearrange
and okay so now I'm looking at uh
invariant yeah tubular representations
in here so that's the case if and only
if these two representations are dual to
each other but for SN the
representations are self-doubles so it's
the same it's yeah I get something here
only if they are the same and so the two
Spectra have to be the same well the two
use have to be the same and so yeah so
that's how I how I can derive that uh
singular values are invariant on the
transpose
all right so then the next um the next
example is to look at yeah what uh the
lab will call three qubits so D equal to
and we have three tensor factors and
then the SL orbits of that space they
are actually known
um and well they are not actually no
they're known in fact they were on the
screen before and I have one slide to
annoy all the pure mathematicians in
this audience who work hard to get their
citations because it's a classic result
and was rediscovered in 2000 uh in the
paper that he last cited before and yeah
this is uh this is doing DSL I I I I I
guess you're saying what great Scholars
physicists are
um
it's a neutral presentation and neutral
conclusion so so now you may maybe yeah
before you're born all right okay so
then it's holding it so it's excited a
thousand six hundred times and you can
say others can't to be true in fact it
isn't true because I took the screenshot
like 18 months ago and now it's like
it's a 2 300 times so it hasn't hasn't
lost its a few all right
okay so uh thanks to this uh so I think
this is the future we should start
publishing 28th 19th century mathematics
and physics literature yeah but the
problem is you can't do it because you
don't get the dragon right
makes it sound fancy
yeah happy is that you exactly all right
so with this uh breakthrough uh
established we can now compare how it
looked to this uh Polito lens
um
all right so what are they I mean we've
seen them before so they are the the
products they are the one which
factorize like two factors versus one uh
they are
this um
whatever tensor and uh yeah this one
which I guess some people call the that
unit tensor I never know anyway so they
have different names they're all known
in their different names and these are
all of course um representatives of
these classes
and then for larger n is if I take the
number of factors maybe larger the
number is this will not no longer be a
finite list but it will be a continuous
list and even the number of parameters
will increase exponentially but you
don't have to worry because the key log
will characterize them all
um
classifying them as we heard before
um in any case so here's the polytokes
to go with it
um the products they are this point Aha
and now come back to your top your own
question all right so we got C2 and
three factors but for every Factor we
only need to retain one number because
it's sum up to one so we get a
three-dimensional uh yeah
three-dimensional plot here so we got a
yeah this one point means all yeah all
the um
the Spectra of every single of these
Maps is one zero right
one then these three lines they are the
ones that factorize as in one point
versus the two every single line is the
GHz like somewhere on here right if you
forget one of the coordinates
um
uh yeah and then this is like this uh
this W state is this pyramid and and the
entire space
um is is is yeah the POI tube associated
with the GH that class of the entire
space
all right now you can use this um you
can use this I guess you can yeah if you
again we call that physically
like these axes are are information you
can you can get very easily right you
just have to interrogate each particle
by itself so if you do that and if you
find some point which lies not in this
upper pyramid but but somehow in this
lower part here so if you violate
um the inequality which defines this
facet then then you know whatever the
pre-image
is I mean you don't have much
information about the pre-image but it
must be in this um
in this GHz type entanglement class
right it must be more Integrity than
that
okay so we can also do it for four
qubits that's yeah still aware where all
the ingredients one needs to actually do
it exclusively have all been worked out
um yes and we come up with uh
so yeah all these um and again I guess
you mentioned this before all these uh
orbits are classified here too and yeah
we get 12 polytopes uh this uh this this
W State before it was associated with
this upper pyramid having this kind of
inequality and kind of we see the same
behavior here there's the analog of that
of that class for example it uh yeah
it's constrained this poly tube is
constrained by a similar inequality the
nine family is the 12 politics
aha so okay so they are not all right
okay so nine families the the term
families even with arbitrary so somebody
actually a physicist also from the start
and I think this time it was actually
not known before sorry well actually ten
they're actually 10.
okay whatever let me answer the question
so now so in the in this week in the in
the three Factor spaces it's a finite
number here it's not a finite number
they are they are uh
yeah and so and so um
and so yeah so so there's a bunch of
it's a continuous family and this family
by the guy who Justified them yeah no I
mean all these orbits uh defending these
boys were cutting rice into nine
families by the guy who classified them
but this is a bit arbitrary right I mean
it's already found natural at the time
but now it says he actually finds a
different classification
thank you
okay so however that might be I mean we
can just that's just uh information that
we have
all right uh so now the the politos will
come four dimensional what you see here
these are different politopes that
that's these are cuts to the third
dimension or the fourth dimension and I
admit to the fact that this slide
probably has no scientific value
whatsoever but these are nice blue
potatoes so anyway I display them how
did you cut so this is some slice from
the fork you uh yeah so exactly so this
these are different polytokes and these
are slices to the fourth axis up and
again I mean it's just an excuse for
having blue things on the screen I can't
read off that myself
all right
um good so I'm
I want to change topic for the final 10
minutes and uh yeah and forget about SL
orbits and entanglement and ask a
different question
um namely to do with crown States
something more Hands-On that physicists
like who solve real problems and like we
care more about and in this context I
also have an open an open problem for
you
all right so okay so again I have to
teach you a bunch of terminology so um
all right the first is a non-interacting
hamiltonian what that is a
non-interacting hamiltonian is a mission
operator
uh which is a sum
Capital eight which is a sum of small
ages with some index and every Summit
here should act non-trivial trivially
only on the date tensor Factor so the
way we had it before
and um it's it's ground state that's the
next piece of terminology is the
eigenvector of the impertonian
associated with the smallest eigenvalue
let's assume for now there's only one
it's it's non-degenerate and okay
for non-interacting hamiltonian the
ground side is a product Vector that's
very easy to see you just take the
lowest this yeah the the eigenvector
associated with the smallest eigenvalue
of every summoned you factor them
together it gives you the smallest the
smallest eigenvector
typical physical hamiltonians
unfortunately are interacting and
involve two particle terms so I have a
sum over
yeah a double index and and each of
these summons now X is not trivially on
two tensor factors
in finding their ground States and also
their lowest eigenvalues is very
important but very computationally hard
and yeah that's a very important problem
in physics note that these hamiltonians
are easy to specify because if I have
D dimensional constituents I just need
to specify every sum and here is a D
Squared by D Squared Matrix so that's
small and I only have n of them so
that's also small but the the space on
which they act is D to the N dimensional
that's exponentially larger
so I can't just use normal linear
algebra to diagonalize this I have to
find better with our algorithms and a
lot of ground state and lowest
eigenvalue means in the second case ah
well this is a linear operator yes and I
for example if I give you these summons
I I then proceed to ask you what is the
lowest eigenvalue
and you think you can solve it but you
can't because you can't just use you
can't just organize it because it acts
on exponentially big space even though I
could specify it officially like the
normal algorithm you're thinking of
cannot be efficiently implemented
and so a lot of many body physics is
just finding different ways of of
getting some information about the
lowest eigenvalue and its eigenvector
out without having to do this numerical
procedure that you have in mind
how computationally hard is this it's
surely the answer is known yeah it's uh
well whatever you want I mean it's NP
hard it's qma complete if you know what
qma means and yeah
yes so even a quantum computer couldn't
solve it unless some funny things happen
in complexity Theory
because this problem is killing me huh
this problem is kill me hard here
so yeah because of that any help is
welcome so anyway
oh wait that's not the only problem
that's the motivation for the next
question
all right so let's be a bit more
specific in what I'm asking all right so
here's the hope and that's what this
should motivate because it's a very uh
it's a bit of a desperate hope so that's
why I put in this disclaimer here that
any help is working so my desperate hope
is this uh maybe we can learn something
by looking at Ground stage through this
moment map let's so let's do this and so
we sat down and did it and uh here's
something we computed and so all right
okay so we we took some
some natural we thought model of uh of a
hamiltonian which is an interact a
non-interacting hamiltonian and then you
have a small parameter that the
interaction and then you turn it up
right so for
for no interaction you get a product
ground state so you are at one vertex of
that polytope
and as you ramp up the interaction you
get a family of hamiltonians you get a
family of ground States
you get a family of Petra and then we
can plot this trajectory if you want of
of uh of eigenvalues inside that
polytope
that's not actually for fermion so the
Hilbert space here is no longer a tensor
product but a totally anti-symmetric
space
and what you find is that
okay so
initially we are on on the boundary of
that of that body talk even on the
vertex and as we ramp out the
interaction then
um the the constraints are almost but
not exactly saturated so more
geometrically we move very close to a
facet but we do not lie on that facet
and this is a actually hard work to do
because you have to go through many
indirect steps you have to solve the
hamiltonian which normally you can't and
then you have to compute the one
particle reduce density these raw raw
J's which normally you can't then you
have to diagonalize them and then you
get this picture
all right and now here's an open problem
and here's the other problem
um okay so 10 subside that map onto a
facet of the polytope are simple in some
way we can make statements about the
pre-image of a facet and here's the
statement again I don't expect anybody
who doesn't already know to understand
it but let me just repeat it for those
who do okay so you take the set of
Weights that lie on the affine hull of a
facet so the vertex and I extended in
all directions there will be more
weights that I that I that I capture and
then
PSI the pre-image of something that Maps
there has non-zero coefficients only
with respect to the associated weight
vectors so in a way
size tensors that map onto the facet
have a sparse representation in a known
basis
it's good if you have a computer and you
want to solve these problems
computationally because uh yeah you just
have to store these coefficients right I
mean it's more memory efficient and
maybe you can do stuff
yeah here's the problem now how stable
is that phenomenon right unfortunately
we see that in models we look at we
don't we are not exactly on the boundary
we are just very close
so is there a sense and I don't even
know what the right metric would be but
is there a sense in which every Cancer
that match close to a facet
is close to the space space spent by the
associated waitresses
and then in low Dimensions uh the
student
uh Kristen Schilling who's uh who's
worked on that he sat down and does the
yeah it's I Don't Know sample randomly
did Scatter Plots and he saw some
inequalities in the scatter plot and
then he proved all of them so in low
Dimension settings one can prove
something but the but this is by put
forth there's no idea how how to attack
this problem in a way that would scale
so that's something I care about so
anybody has an idea to
what is then I'd be very happy because
thank you but peace
in what senses the moment map is
continuous not an answer oh sure yes
okay I mean this we know it we know
there is there is a sense in which that
is true yeah so what exactly are you
asking for example some kind of
Lipschitz concert
so something explicit
so so the current one map yeah you have
some sort of orbit and you intersect you
you typically point the point you sort
of move that until it meets like the the
um
uh I I guess the door to the door to the
tors or something and that are orbit and
you intersect the orbit with that and
you get a pile of dope so so you could
also view it is there's this known
linear space inside of your vector space
and you're moving that on top of the
point you have and there's and and the
intersection of this translated in your
space with your ovaries is also the
polyhope so I guess in essentially you
you then are this is a orthogonal action
but it's not about okay I'm not quite
sure okay I think my time is up so let
me put up my summary slide and then I go
to the current moment map yeah okay so I
I have my understanding of what you said
and I don't think it solves the problem
but maybe I'm misunderstanding you maybe
put my summary and then uh I I will
finish in time I think I have 10 seconds
all right so here's my summary uh for
the implied products yeah there's a
there's one but many indices singular
value problem
uh of tensors and the set of these
singular values they form a convex body
tube and these can be characterized in
principle using a representation Theory
and four geometers
yeah there's another application of of
homelessness Ah that's it
foreign
okay you take the family of hamiltonians
again this is a perturbative expansion
around the hamiltonian that's not
interacting right so then you get a
family of states which will also treat
perturbatively then you get a family of
reduced densities which also sleep
adoptively you look protectively at that
spectrum and then you plot what you get
in here this might actually be
mathematical and then it's not
perturbatively but of course we can also
yeah we can do it analytically
perturbatively which sounds like it's
not so hard but it's actually really
hard so yeah it's again I have to it's
Christians because that work he worked
very hard to get that
yeah but yeah I think this is a this
mathematical simulation but but we can
kind of unders we can understand this
Behavior
around around the non-interactive case
and we know so yeah we know that this
conclusion that we are
close to the facet but not only it's
actually true
it's not just in America
and the question is what conclusion to
draw from this about about the premature
I'm
I listen to you later
uh David go back to that slide where you
have this non-corrected having to go in
versus the oh yeah this one so you know
the each J that you have on top that is
essentially identity tense identity and
almost accepted James yeah exactly it's
the same sense in which we have it I
pass it oh thank you
this exactly yeah I see so it's a sum
we've got all J right yeah some of the
terms like this yes sure this thing has
all around two maybe that's why it's
easy and the other one when you have IJ
then the borderline is probably very big
so this is the sum over OG you can
approximate arbitrarily well with just a
tensor rank too maybe that's why it's
easy and when you don't have you know
when you have eye Jade and the
borderline probably is very big
so you want to figure out how to do the
other one thing I did right as one
operator that you have to figure out
yeah it's um yeah it's interesting I I
it's a it's it's an approach people in
physics wouldn't haven't taken so far
right I mean the the complexity of these
problems is is a lot is known about that
but certainly
um terms like like border rank of the
hamiltonian have never have never been
used to establish them so it might be
interesting to to see whether this this
way of thinking match up somehow I don't
know but is it approximating right or
how else were you approximate you were
prospered by some or fewer terms right
and that is precisely how hot whether
you can approximate arbitrary of all
that no but I mean let's say I mean
there's no at this point there's no
approximation right I mean let's see uh
here
I mean this is just
let's take that at the definition stage
yeah that is the Matrix you want to know
the lowest eigenvalue of and that's by
definition make that exact then given as
I give to you these h i j k terms which
are small
they're asking for the ground state
energy the lowest eigenvalue that that
is very hard
yeah and um and of course it's Asians
also this map this operator is also a
tensor but this is not somehow
a a property that has featured in the
analysis and maybe we should I don't
know
same David again